and they decide and you have read it uh
do you do you require uh Miss Boyle to
recite it to you
would you said if I said will Terry take
it as red
and he said that about the report we
have a response whose name I'd forgotten
and uh and Allison acting on behalf of
uh you've read those objections
again
can we take those red or would you like
to expand on the result
let's see further
on the 9th of August we formed a
licensing subcommittee to consider who
fought to park or what the junction of
Ashley Road and the center of hail
on the 3rd of September this is serving
alcohol
notice which prohibits members of the
public from
and two that the statutory requirement
that no more than 500 people can be on
the premises at any one time cannot be
achieved due to the nature of the public
space and the number of persons wishes
to serve that event being the tour of
Britain foreign
matter at this meeting and in particular
the prevention of crime and disorder
Public Safety and prevention of nuisance
irrespective tree trading protection
spaces order
we're also the view that the proposed
sighting of the vehicle would cause an
obstruction and prevent a risk to the
public safety
and we have therefore resolved that the
notice should be canceled
in such circumstances it's not necessary
for us to consider the capacity argument
noting that it would be singularly
impossible to define the physical area
in which the numerical cap would apply
in summary
the notice is denied
thank you okay can we
record that
and can I ask if there are any other
activities that we're going to undertake
in relation to this there aren't China
right and we're now call it in relation
to the other matter but I think we're
still missing an applicant so we may
need to stand matters down for a few
minutes okay and can I say thank you